[Music]
please welcome Academy Award nominee Amy
Adams
[Music]
would the unseen shark in Jaws be is
menacing without this with the first
contact made with the alien spaceship in
Close Encounters be is thrilling without
this memorable sound with our hearts be
quite as rapidly as rocky stands proudly
waving his arms on the top steps of the
Philadelphia Museum of Art without this
of course the answer to those questions
and a thousand more like them is a
resounding no for those glorious moments
we have to thank the brilliantly
inventive composers who create the
musical scores this year the nominees
for original score are
[Music]
atonement by Dario Marian le The Kite
Runner by Alberto Iglesias Michael
Clayton by James Newton Howard
ratatouille by Michael Giacchino
3:10 to Yuma by Marco Beltrami
and the Oscar goes to Dario Marian le
for a tournament
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was that was a very long walk who
felt like I'm I feel like a very lucky
man
thank you very much Academy I'm very
lucky because I was part of a of a
fantastic group of people that made a
fantastic film it's I think it's it's
called movie because it's a very moving
film and I'm really grateful above all
to Joe Wright the director to you have
included me in this fantastic group of
gifted people I'm very grateful to my
good friends for supporting me through
lots of things through these years and
my family who are very much my girls and
my father my mother thank you for
passing on a very deep and strong love
of music thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he sleeps till awake our next presenter
Tom Hanks has won two Academy Awards
although he was not nominated tonight so
if you ask me he has no place being here
it's got a lot of nerve that guy ladies
and gentlemen Tom Hanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]